aucune maltraitance envers mes bébés et
ça ne t'inquiète pas que le
professionnel l'ont bien relevé d'accord
les réseaux sociaux ont eu un énorme
impact et une énorme importance dans
cette affaire donc je m'exprimerai pas
de mauvaises une très mauvaise
dans cette affaire en fait s'il y a une
rumeur sur toi moi comme ça on la coupe
ce soir et comme ça c'est terminé OK
je suis une très bonne maman je suis sûr
je suis pas une maman parfaite
tout ce que j'ai fait tout a été pour
eux et uniquement pour eux dans leur
intérêt j'ai jamais fait de mal à la
maison
ils sont ils ont tout ils ont confondu
lui ils ont tout ils ont les vaccins à
jour ils ont tout ils ont tout l'amour